Moscow is trying to claim these four
regions of Ukraine as part of Russia
following staged referendums that were
widely criticized as a sham even though
Ukraine and its allies refused to
recognize the regions as anything but
Ukrainian Russia's attempted land grab
has helped usher in a new and
potentially more dangerous phase of the
war here's why
the four regions where the staged votes
took place are crucial to Russia's war
strategy luhansk Donetsk zapparija and
Herson cementing control of them would
help Russia secure its desired land
bridge to Crimea which Russia annexed in
2014 after holding the same kind of
widely criticized process holding these
territories would also help choke
Ukraine's economy off from Key waterways
plus Russia has stated that the quote
liberation of the Don boss which
includes luhansk and Donetsk is a top
objective right now all four regions are
under at least partial Russian control
and ahead of the vote pro-russian
propaganda filled the streets people
passed out pamphlets and billboards
plugged things like Russian payouts to
mothers for having kids Russian
traditions and values like marriage and
Russian history which this sign says
cannot be canceled as for the so-called
voting video shows armed guards
overseeing the process in some places
and residents appeared to cast ballads
in the open before stuffing them into
see-through ballot boxes some people
said they were being threatened and told
that voting was mandatory regardless of
the results some analysts say that
Russia could lose some or all of this
territory to Ukrainian forces who have
gained momentum and retaken critical
areas in recent weeks Russia's new
territorial claims aren't likely to
change Ukraine's strategy that's
according to my colleague Ian who's been
in Europe covering the conflict I spoken
to military officials from Ukraine who
say these votes which they call fake
referendums will have no bearing at all
on the way we're conducting our military
operation so if Ukrainian forces aren't
changing course why do the so-called
referendums matter they're important to
the Kremlin and President Vladimir Putin
for a few reasons first they could help
Putin justify a full military draft down
the road if he chooses to call one and
they support his case for the partial
mobilization he announced before the
vote
which he says is necessary to protect
Russia's sovereignty and territorial
Integrity the announcement prompted some
Russians to leave the country but if
Russia says that these four regions are
Russian it can justify sending
conscripts in to try and fight to defend
them and these regions make up 15
percent of Ukraine's territory so
military analysts say Russia will need a
lot of support if it wants to try and
hold the line secondly the staged
referendums could help appease some
hardliners in Russia who have grown
critical of the Kremlin strategy after
humiliating setbacks many of them have
called for a full-scale war and even
retaliatory strikes against NATO members
who are backing Ukraine the criticism is
posing a fresh challenge for Putin who
has tried to silence any backlash
against the war third the referendums
could open the door to a bigger and more
dangerous conflict around the same time
that the staged voting process and
mobilization were announced Putin
pledged to use all means at Russia's
disposal including nuclear weapons to
defend its territorial Integrity
Putin could try to use the staged
referendums and the nuclear threats to
negotiate an end to the war on his terms
even though Ukrainian president
velodimir zielinski has said he won't
negotiate until all Russian forces have
left Ukrainian land we can return the
Ukrainian flag to our entire territory
we can do it with the force of arms but
perhaps an even bigger priority for
Putin is to get the West to back off its
support of Ukraine it's the Western Arms
that have really turned the time of the
war it's these long-range Rockets mostly
from the U.S have allowed them to really
push Russia back and so he he's trying
to frighten Western allies away from
continuing to give support to Ukraine
it's too early to say if his actions
will have an impact but for now Western
leaders are calling for more sanctions
against Russia and expressing even
greater support for Ukraine